[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parmi les textes classiques de la
littérature française les mémoires
d'outretombe de Château brillant
apparaissent à beaucoup comme un
monument à ce point impressionnant qu'on
hésite à aller le regarder de trop près
aussi faut-il s'incliner devant le
travail effué par les responsables de la
collection quarau chez galimar leur
nouvelle édition de ce grand œuvre il et
anoté avec goût et simplicité devrait
permettre à de nouveaux lecteurs
d'oublier leur prévention et de se
rapprocher de Château brillant ce sont
donc deux forts volumes de près de 2000
pages chacun leur typographie leur
reliure souple leur fabrication même
apparaissent comme autant d'incitations
à les ouvrir à plonger au hasard dans
cette œuvre sans pareil composé dans le
désordre chronologique au long de 30
années qu'importe la connaissance ou la
méconnaissance que l'on a du héros de
son ascendance de ses amours de sa
carrière personne jamais n'a écrit comme
lui notre langue et personne avant lui
n'avait à ce point comme plus tard
Marcel prou ainsi recomposer le passé
dans l'avant-propos l'un de ses
meilleurs textes Jean dormesson rappelle
l'exemple de Rousseau en ses confession
et soulignant que châteaubillant a vécu
à cheval sur deux siècles il voit
l'image de sa perpétuelle contradiction
lui qui fut toute sa vie hanté par
Napoléon au point de prétendre à tort
être né la même année que lui retombé de
Bonaparte et de l'Empire à ceux qui les
a suivi écrit château brillant pourtant
royaliste c'est tombé de la réalité dans
le néant du sommet de la montagne dans
un
[Musique]
goufre